[Musique]
bonjour bonjour ma été je crois que la
bourse était pas prêt gonflé aujourd'hui
comment elle avait fait le marché 1
ça arrive d'avoir pour tourner un petit
peuple à vivre à vos mains je la crains
que ça ne soit pas seulement avoue que
ça arrive de temps en temps non ça c'est
pas une raison pour faire des mauvaises
choses dans social de la bonne cuisine
quand même bien sûr si vous aviez
pressez vous avez fait le marché en
vitesse payer des gens bien où on n'a
pas envie de faire la pluie du matin au
soir sans que ça arrive aussi alors on
peut faire quelque chose de 8,2 bon
alors peu large et en peu d'autres temps
qu'est ce que vous nous proposez et bien
aujourd'hui on va faire des brochettes
de porc qu aux ananas et aux pruneaux
avec ces deux fruits mais c'est sûrement
bon original est bon mais comme c'est un
vite fait vous avez peut-être prévu à un
plat de complément voilà on va faire la
cervelle de veau au vin rouge la
cervelle il semble qu'on avait déjà fait
mais c'était de la cervelle de motorola
mais on peut en faire deux victoires
face au nacional et ça le débat lié à la
cervelle d'agneau y aller sans vie de
moutons qui a laissé leur valve de porc
il ya la mienne est à la vente et les
serveurs de tout le monde et celle là
c'est de vos ébats très bien et alors
vous allez à faire avec du vin rouge et
vin rouge à six originales comme reçoit
la barre barça à la bourse et de
recettes
il vous faut quoi il nous faut bien
évidemment du vin rouge il faut de la
ventrèche il faut de la nana de
l'échalote des petits oignons de l'union
des champignons de l'ail des pruneaux
bien entendu un petit bouquet garni du
citron une cervelle et puis du port
classé du loup en morceaux de l'homme
s'est cassé le filet mignon
mon fils est mignon nous a narré par et
ça se dessine très bien et par quoi
allons nous commencer par les brochettes
laquelle d'abord c'est le pruneau alors
comment avez vous fait la la j'ai fait
macérer la viande dans de l'huile
d'olive avec godec un bouquet garni une
charlotte delahaye peuvent pas fait pour
l'insérer bien salée par et voilà la
viande coupée un petit gain de couper en
petits cubes dans la côté vous avez ces
commerces et des pruneaux qui macèrent
dans notre manière
tendu c'est bon ça si on n'a pas de sous
du tout on aura même inséré dans l'eau
dans le futur mais c'est mieux avec les
remet à new york un petit goût de
quelque chose me donne du fer alors ça
vous l'aviez fait le matin avant d'avoir
bien travaillé
voilà ça alors il faut que ça mais c'est
encore un tout petit peu et on va faire
une annonce pour l'instant et on va
faire ça parce que là ça serait tout de
suite alors l'entraîneur comme un blâme
la voilà et vous allez je vous le mets
de côté pour que vous coupiez la la
viande en petits cubes
je vais couper la nana aussi d'abord
vous allez voir ça les deux bouts en
deux voilà en quatre vous enlevez eater
qui est toujours empêché m
c'est un peuvent faire on fait attention
à vos doigts avec votre grand couteau
qui coupent bien je suis assuré voilà on
va mettre tous à la poubelle après je
vais couper mais man / de viande et vous
allez en brochets tout ça oui tu t'en
des mousquetaires je suis pas sûr qu'ils
avaient beaucoup d'ananas on le connaît
déjà un bien sûr mais en brochets on
savait ça alors la warner
elle ne posait pas de problème de ce
côté rapproché de toutes les manières de
saint leu et oui on va le coupé en deux
parce que c'est très épais là je crois
que vous avez déjà de quoi faire une
brochette et non à peu près voilà allez
non branché maintenant commander en fils
et c'est gagné
du lard ou autre chose ou malgré tout la
viande de porc du tout et l'ananas
c'est quand même bien facile a dû vite
fait c'est et voilà ça c'est pas faut
pas avoir le bac et pour faire ça non et
puis c'est fait en cinq minutes j'espère
que vous regardez bien la recette
parce que c'est un peu compliqué à faire
il faut connaître la recette par coeur
de sa et les manipulations sont contre
ikea
tennis par an ça y est alors pour le
pronom va faire la même chose
c'est exactement la même chose un
morceau de viande et un poisson de
viande et un pruneau vous allez les
dénoyauter les pruneaux cétacés
dénoyautées et on mettra ça sur
peut-être sur la braise voilà une aux
pruneaux et une nana chacune on a deux
oui et on voit très bien la différence
entre la viande cameline et oui qui est
beaucoup plus par et l'avion de doute
france voilà et je vais les saler
poivrer mais juste celle qui ne peut
m'arriver c'est à dire celle à la nana
et on va mettre à griller alors la
cheminée puisqu'on a la chance d'avoir
une très belle cheminée bien et les
braises sont superbes
voilà là il faut les surveiller pour pas
dire dix minutes 5 minutes et on va les
regarder ça dépanne à la braise rôles
agressif qu'il faudra au minimum dix
minutes quand même oui alors ça nous
laisse le temps de faire la servane bien
sûr vous les avez fait d'égorger dans de
l'eau très sale et ensuite vous les avez
bien français voilà et maintenant alors
là j'ai fait chauffer bouillir du verre
et l'âge du bouillon de viande trois
viandes c'est à dire beaucoup
comme toujours un peu de ports un peu de
vos un peu de bluff et tous les légumes
qu'on met dans tous les bouillons voir j
mais dans ce bouillon je vais y mettre
un bouquet garni
oui un oignon que je vais couper en
quatre mais en servant un peu de sel de
poivre
pas trop de sel parce que vous rappelons
que l'esrb long des gorges dans nos
salons il va se faire de quand même et
oui voilà et les cervelles tout
simplement
alors là je voulais mettre dix minutes
parce que servait ensuite cuire environ
10 minutes on espère bien l'entendre je
passe d'une minute seulement après
l'avoir lemaitre non et ensuite nuit
alors là j'ai mis mon agresseur chauffe
et je veux y mettre mes petits oignons
quand vous dites de la grèce et de la
graisse de canard toujours de chez lui
dans les landes la chance d'avoir des
petits oignons nouveaux ça c'est bien
meilleur
cette délicieuse la voilà quelques-uns
et puis les girolles de jean mas de la
chance d'en avoir aussi des fresh
d'agréable on a toujours de la chanson
et puis les petits lardons c'est ce que
vous appelez de la ventrèche autrement
dit baba ladde poitrine de porc ou père
morceau le jeu mais pratiquement partout
parce que c'était celle à 1 et saler
poivrer déjà un peu et laisse présager
bien sûr et tout assaisonné ya même il y
en a même un peu de lag mais là n est
que seuls saler et poivrer c'est tout
oui voilà
saler poivrer mais pas fumer ah non non
non voilà les salaires pendant ce temps
de brochettes que ben je crois qu'elles
sont pas si mal que ça elle dort bien
son nom
en valais les voit et on va s'en occuper
il à vous allez entendre que tout ça
fonde bien gentiment dans la poêle et
que nos cervelles soit point de lanvaux
jus très partie des biens furent dix
minutes passées
ça vous paraît bien la cervelle et ben
vous me la donnez là il ya les goûters
forte mais qu'est ce que vous allez
faire avec et bien vous et je veux la
passer au chinois
la regardez moi je vais là je vous dis
en chinois et on va presser tous ses
petits légumes dans l'union mais tout ça
me paraît très bien comme substance les
ajournés pas trop épaisses et j'ai de la
jolie revanche les petits légumes à côté
ils sont beaux harrison gentiment tout
près autant digue régiment ou
sympathique la regardez moi ça c'est ça
va être beau parent est très bien très
bien on a peint peut peut-être la
cervelle avec sandwich comme on dit
élégamment élégamment élégamment et
jolimont ya pas de crème en rajouter
tout est bien merci jean bien sûr que si
vous n'y pensez pas à fait incroyable ça
oh vous me l'avez soufflé n'est pas ça
rires c'est inutile il faut toujours lui
du retour
une sueur sûr il faut bien la crème
fraîche ça y est c'est bien voilà
et bien et alors là un petit peu alors
je veux vous savez légalement comme
d'habitude anna span poli pas trop pour
que ça ne nous voient pas la détruire
c'est suffisant a bien un qui a l'art
ensuite et petits légumes et petits
légumes
regardez comme ils sont jolies les
prisonniers hommes alors les jeunes
qu'on peut faire avec autre chose et
bien sûr il se trouve qu'on en avait
mais on peut mettre des champignons de
paris tout simplement là on a de la
chance nous entoure de chance d'avoir ce
qu'il faut maïté on va pas dire que
c'est long à faire comme non non c'est
vraiment des choses faciles se parle on
est c'est beau pas beau ça s'est passé
dépassant ses délicieux formé de
personnes rappelez-vous anormalement
2,10 rêve et vous vous savez sur deux
soirées une une cervelle et alors ça
c'est une assiette journalites et oui
pour des appétits plus modeste personne
vous peut-être qu'il est temps d'aller
voir les brochettes voir comment elles
sont l aigle est présenté dans leurs
plans elles sont grillés juste ou un
bien joli joli
voilà attention pas vous brûler maïtena
alors celles qui sont foncés n'ont pas
eu un coup de feu c'est simplement parce
qu'il ya des pruneaux alterné va falloir
c'est plus foncé que la naf et puis la
morna regardez moi ce palmier et que
vous avez c'est un effort de décoration
là attention de pas le faire tomber
non quand vous va dire la racine n'est
pas tellement bien prise mais
regardez-moi ça c'est joli alors ça
c'est votre côté ça c'est le mien je
crois qu'on peut inviter nos amoureux
quand même une brochette pour chacun ça
ira encore ça sera bien partage étaient
habitués à partager
et bien voilà une grande famille ont
partagé un maillot et avouer que quand
même en rentrant du travail c'est pas
long pour se faire plaisir
non un peu de foin dix minutes et ça y
est je peux vous dire que ça sent bon je
sens l'ananas jusqu'ici bon et puis si
le matin on a eu la sagesse de faire un
peu des gorges et ses rebelles s'est pas
plus l'on sait pas plus lourdes ont fait
un bon repas en commun
simple joli il manque deux choses je
crois peut-être un petit peu de riz pour
accompagner on peut l'accompagner ce
qu'on veut et riz et puis l'essentiel
est quoi le coup de rouge leghzaoui un
petit coup de rouge un petit peu de
peine un petit peu ce qu'il faut quand
même on vous voir l' envie d'inviter
pierrot oui ce soir alors que dire de
venir et même vous si vous avez votre
époux il peut venir notre forme en fait
venu à 4 et quant à vous si vous n'avez
pas beaucoup de temps ce soir et que
vous avez envie commune de passer une
bonne soirée
réfléchissez qui vous allez invités puis
penserez aux brochettes de porc aux
pruneaux à l'ananas suite faire est
encore temps de passer une bonne soirée
bon courage au revoir bon courage à
richelle à tous
[Musique]